я
довідки теж рада що з посиленим
міністерство вас вид і науки України
зус чи ми міністерство народні по
sweet епохи ми змогли stella ти ідею
щоб за раз починається вже для
україни у 2017 наче там ще юпітер і
мгу
про та ми включили say вікна з найгірших пізу
саме на дала
польша я хочу за раз ви служать та україну
взято не з польші за такого викупу
ринку я до нас теж було потрібно а був
відключилася
кольору світіння також широку
всім експертам організації економічні
страції розвитку річки до покращилася за
духовок щоб твій проект включенням
україни кубізм
став реальним тепер праворуч за нам цьому
що нам до втц напише і зруби ти всіх
правильним є такі семінари такі
умовляння не кличуть усі експерти буніну
випадковий робочий та важливий вид щоб у
се що ми з робом кутів релевантним і
тих результати ці метри моєму пули з
правді об'єктивним та
yaki-da допоможе нам дали ви буду досвід та
нашу про свиню стратегію в Україні